welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Anthony Mason with Tony to copal Gayle
king's officer Jericka Duncan is with us
a Washington State woman who once ran
for public office in Colorado is accused
of trying to kidnap a three week old
baby she's expected to be arraigned
tomorrow Juliette Parker and her teenage
daughter are suspected of posing as
photographers and drugging a new mom to
try and steal her infant Carter Evans is
tracking the case Carter is Parker still
in jail not anymore she was released
Sunday afternoon on a 50-thousand dollar
bond now since her arrest authorities
tell us more than 10 people say she came
to their home to take photos
investigators believe Parker was
searching for the baby she wanted to
steal authorities say Juliette Parker
used social media to lure in
unsuspecting moms offering free
maternity photos she said she wanted to
build her portfolio but detectives
allege her real motive was much more
sinister she wanted a girl
and she wanted him five weeks around
younger so she could raise it herself
take it out of state and pretend that
was a newborn of her own a mom in
Washington State answered the post
inviting Parker into her home three
times
police say the woman spotted Parker
taking selfies with the baby and wiping
down her fingerprints from items she
touched inside the home during the third
visit
authorities say Parker and her 16 year
old daughter gave the woman a cupcake
the mom suddenly began vomiting and
feeling numb and drowsy she told the two
to leave and call 9-1-1 only to realize
her house keys were stolen basically she
was drugged
they put drugs in a cupcake she ate it
for the temp to take her kid Parker and
her daughter were arrested at their
house about 40 miles south of Seattle
she used her sleeve to open the front
door and when she came into the house
she wouldn't even sit in the chair as
she sat on the ground
Victoria Mora says something seemed off
about Parker when she met her after
responding to the Facebook post Parker
took these maternity photos and was
supposed to be inside the delivery room
with her but as it turns out she gave
birth the day Parker was arrested I was
in shock but I also didn't want to
believe it
because I was just upset about it it
ultimately affects our economy Parker
unsuccessfully ran for mayor of Colorado
Springs last year
authorities say the 38 year old operated
under several aliases I think this
should be a warning to other moms it
makes me anxious to know that people
like that can be some manipulative and
really work their way into your life and
it's so easy to get caught up in it now
Parker's been charged with attempted
kidnapping and assault her attorney
declined to speak with us and
authorities haven't released details
about her daughter because she's a minor
as for the alleged victim she has
already been released from the hospital
Tony well that's some good news there
shocking allegations Carter thank you
very much leave that he already has a
daughter yeah I don't understand it at
all and and the other woman was very
lucky it didn't happen or very lucky
yeah all right Carter thank you very
much